so who would like help you do use yep
all right let's do it all right now what
I'm gonna do is just set up the question
first just so we're all on the same page
and then we'll start to think about
what's we understand the question what
we might be able to use to help us get
to the single okay so you've got the set
up of two touching circles they
intersect they're right there at C a and
B the wording of the question says what
is it it's a bit vague it says a
straight line touches them those circles
at a and B since it only names two
points in there are two circles what I
think it's fair to gather from that is
that they're tangents okay or they're
it's a shared tangent I guess is why
we'd say okay so we're required to hear
that ACB forms a right angle okay so
what I've done is rather than label it
as a right angle which I don't know to
be the case yet I just highlight it in
some way if you got a color I encourage
you to do that because especially when a
diagram gets messy it's like oh okay
this is where I'm going this is the
feature I want to focus on okay now
that's the question
as it stands I've put it in these
centers here because as we know if you
like I don't know what you do want here
you start to construct radii right
because radii are all equal they're very
very useful to use so where my I
construct radii on these circles any
suggestions you can name them right a X
and X C okay now just pause for a second
there's more to do but what I want to
point out is I've talked about color
before I'm going to put these radii in
is the same color because then it's sort
of like a website should go well that's
terrible
it's sort of a visual cue for me that
these things are the same and I can see
it instantly right I know you can um I
know you can add like a little dash to
say all these things are the same but
often those dashes kind of get lost in
the mix okay so there's a pair of equal
radii what were the other ones you were
gonna put on CY and B Y fantastic so
just like before I'm gonna put these
guys in the same color but you notice
it's a different color to the other ones
because these are Ward's are there
different sized circles okay right now
stay
these color themes when you've created
these radio I you have created triangles
did you notice that this is familiar
right what kinds of triangles have you
created isosceles triangles right so I'm
going to get equal angles going around I
might start naming some so for example
in triangle ax C which are the equal
angles which one of the names ex-ac is
one of the base angles and X CA that one
there okay so let's just give him a name
I'm just thinking here right if this is
alpha then we'll make this one alpha as
well okay on the right hand side at the
biggest circle
I mean I've used alphas what would you
like me to call the angles in this
triangle
how about beta so you've got a base
angles here and here okay now what else
do you know about this what else can we
use in this diagram any suggestions here
rush Hey and B see a B yeah okay so
we're gonna suggest that this guy up
here I'll go back to my alpha color
we're suggesting that this is 90 degrees
minus alpha but we actually just take a
step back first to realize why that's
the case why is that 90 minus alpha okay
if a B is a tangent then it's
perpendicular to the radius at the point
of contact does that make sense so
actually there is a right angle here and
so that's why you've got right angle
alpha at 90 minus alpha they are all
that up 280 same thing happening over
here right there's where's the 90 minus
beta a B C is 90 minus bit more on color
90 minus beta for the same reason yeah
so let me just mark that in now this
point where super super close we're very
very close if I've got two angles in
this ABC triangle the biggest one that
I've got here then the two angles will
give me the third angle right what is
this third angle
if the able sum of the triangle is 180
degrees then this Plus this Plus this
mystery angle let's actually write this
out ACB is our mystery angle plus BAC
which you know is 90 minus alpha and ABC
which is 90 minus beta right these guys
are all equal to 180 degrees and you
have your reason for this right angle
sum of triangle ABC yeah okay so what
can I do with this this one here yeah I
could do that I'm going to come to that
in a second but this is what we sort of
point out before so I'll come back to
your line of logic in a minute because
just two ways around the same obstacle
okay have a look look at the angles
right so can you see you've got 90 and
90 here and a 180 so what could I do
both sides that might make this nice and
simple I can just yeah once I subtract
these and add alpha plus beta to both
sides you get ACB being alpha plus beta
is that okay so this mystery angle I can
say either the way that Roger stated it
or the way that we've stated just now
that's alpha plus beta okay but look
using the property that Roger is just
talking about XC y is a straight line
it's 180 degrees so therefore I would
say well I'd rather like this alpha plus
alpha plus beta plus beta you could
write it immediately as a collected like
to his form but this makes clear it's
three angles that make this up that's
180 degrees reason angle sum of a
straight line which we've proved earlier
so now I have a look to alpha this this
looks familiar doesn't it to alpha plus
2 beta is 180 so what's our final line
there we go there's the right angle we
were looking for